[Music]
today we're going to talk about how
artificial intelligence and how my
company is working with Google to help
power global food production my name is
Craig Ansel and I'm the founder and CEO
of a company called Camp three out of
Atlanta Georgia we have a product called
farm wave artificial intelligence can
play a huge role in important industries
such as global food production just to
name a few if I were to ask you what is
this you would tell me it's an apple but
what if I said now prove it to me prove
to me that this is an apple how do you
know that because when we were kids
preschool or kindergarten we all saw the
same thing the little flashcard with the
picture and it said Apple what about
that that's an apple too but it doesn't
look like that so what do you mean it's
an apple what about that one that looks
different too or that these are all
apples but in global food production
using artificial intelligence we have to
prove it and not only would we have to
prove it that is an apple but all the
pathogen pest and weed infestations that
it in fact could infect any crop out
there welcome to the challenges of AI
and plant pathology and agriculture it's
a daunting task to use things like image
recognition to identify pathogen and
pest infestation in crops or plants
tomatoes citrus row crops anything early
on but this is one of the most critical
stages in growing food if we can
identify pathogen pest infestation early
enough that means we could spray less
chemicals that mean
we have less crop destruction bigger
crop yields that could mean more food
this is an industry that is really
important globally because we all need
to eat doctor Fei Fei Lee has said it
best build a new data set and so a farm
wave that's what we set out to do we
have searched all around the world
universities large stakeholder
corporations farmers small holders to
capture imagery and build a data set
that is curated and catalogued for image
recognition for Plant Pathology
and reducing crop loss farm wave is an
app that connects people in agriculture
with their farm and technology and each
other it's more than just the artificial
intelligence but that's the real
powerhouse behind it in the past couple
years that we've been developing farm
wave we've done pilots and proof of
concepts around the world with large
corporations such as Monsanto Syngenta
Bayer small farmers from India France
the United States all around the world
and found out that if we could get farm
wave into the hands of farmers all
around the world we have a really good
shot at reducing crop destruction by
twenty to thirty percent one of the
components is communities in enabling
farmers to talk to each other today they
use things like Twitter and Instagram
but in their day to day job and how fast
they move and all the tasks that have to
happen on the farm they're using Twitter
and Instagram but all that all the noise
of the news and everything else they
follow is kind of getting stuck in the
middle not to mention you have some
growers who grow for large stakeholder
companies where they're doing plant
trials and that information is
proprietary and shouldn't be out on the
public web farm wave gives them a closed
loop community where researchers drama
stand farmers alike can collaborate by
building field reports in near real-time
this allows us to have the data right in
the palm of their hands there's a lot
happening in agriculture today you know
all around the world there's there's
different companies that are
making attempts at autonomous vehicles
John Deere has been doing it for a very
long time we've had autonomous tractors
for decades they move a lot slower and
there's nobody in their way but they've
been doing it for a while
unmanned aerial vehicles satellite
imagery hyperspectral color imagery all
of this data is very important to
agriculture and there are many many
companies around the world trying to
make an impact into how we could better
make use of all of this data to make
better decisions in in our farming
Howard Buffett wrote the book forty
chances if you think about it a farmer
has in their lifetime an average of 40
chances to get it right and that's it
because everything that they do their
day-to-day is very seasonal everything
plants in the spring they harvest and
get the results in the fall whatever
didn't work they can try it again next
year a farmer in Indiana Chris Tom of
Tom farms they farm about 45,000 acres
they're one of the largest growers in
the United States he said something to
me once don't add more technology on top
of existing technology for the sake of
adding new technology so we're trying to
Train things from the ground up with
farm wave and artificial intelligence to
work with the devices that they're
already carrying around with them or
that they're already using today such as
unmanned aerial vehicles and even some
of the machinery we leverage a lot of
technologies within Google cloud
platform recently we've been an alpha
one of the Alpha companies working with
Auto ml and we have a partnership with
the University of Georgia agriculture
extension which is where we are from
Atlanta where we had what is called a
consortium for Internet imagery database
system owned by University of Georgia at
about 19 other universities around the
world have participated in it is 20
years of imagery data on over 35,000
plant species so we've worked closely
with the University of Georgia and we
got a copy of this database we started
classifying and labeling and tagging and
running imagery through farm wave
it's been very very challenging 20 19 18
years ago we didn't have the kind of
mobile phones that we have today so the
pictures really aren't usable they're
not a very good quality but as we
started to see more recent imagery we
have better quality some are good
pictures some are not in Plant Pathology
you have to get up really really close
and get a really good picture of a leaf
to get really early detection where
you'll have an impact that you could
identify a pathogen or a pest make a
recommendation and a treatment and put
the input in the field we also got early
on into counting sequences today farmers
will help predict yield by counting the
kernels on an ear of corn they do that
with a sharpie now I don't know how many
of you have spent time farming but if
you are in the South Georgia Heat in
July with a sharpie and you're trying to
count kernels on an ear of corn it's
awful and by the time you roll it around
some of the sweat in your hands washed
off the the marker and you don't really
have a good accurate count so using some
of the vision API technology we've
developed a system that allows you to
take a picture of the kernel of the ear
of corn rotated 180 degrees take another
picture and it counts it in about two
seconds we've been 95-plus percent
accurate on these counts consecutively
indoors outdoors regardless of different
light levels this is an increase by a 17
to 20 percent of what was acceptable
according to the Iowa corn board later
this year we're going to be launching
what's in the middle image which is
called stand counts stand counts allow
farmers to know how many they have in a
given row sometimes this imagery can be
taken by UAVs sometimes it's taken on
the ground cluster counts and tomatoes
wine grapes helping to predict yield the
more decisions that farmers can make
earlier on the better it is for overall
global food production the image
recognition for us was about time now
let me give you an idea of what it would
start like here's how it's typically
done today a farmer goes out into the
field or satellite takes a picture or a
drone takes a picture and they see that
there's a distress in an area of the
field then they'll send somebody out and
they'll take a picture
maybe the farmer knows what it is maybe
they don't because even today we still
see new diseases that pop up so they say
okay I don't really know what this is
I've got to get this to an agronomist
but I live out in the middle of nowhere
in Iowa in a sea of corn the nearest
University is four hours away so I make
a phone call to my local agronomist he's
two states away he'll get to me maybe
next week so he reaches out to the
University they say we can get somebody
to come out and take a look in a couple
of days so they come out they take a
look if they know what it is they make a
recommendation they write a prescription
and the farmer calls their dealer and
they come out and put down either an
herbicide fungicide pesticide whatever
it might be they don't know what it is
they have to do some further research
maybe that takes a couple more days
maybe another week depending on climate
weather traits whatever they may have
this could spread this could spread from
five percent of their crop to 20 to 30
to 40 decimating their yield losing food
for us it's about time farm wave and the
image recognition capability makes this
happen in a matter of seconds now 35,000
species from the University of Georgia
20 years of crop imagery we are just
getting started this is a huge database
corn alone and all the diseases in corn
has taken us several years just to just
to kind of get under our belt because if
you remember the pictures from the
apples we have to look at a crop in all
of its different stages and every
disease for that crop in all of its
different stages from early on to 20%
severe 60% severe fully decimated to get
accurate results our library of imagery
is one of the only one we know of today
and that we have been told that it
improperly validated by PhD level
pathologists and entomologists from
around the world
but we have to have high accuracy so we
have to have that but it takes more time
when farmers go out to a field if you've
been through farmland you'll see these
placards it tells us what kind of crop
is is being planted right there in this
case it's a pioneer version using the
Google vision API farmers are able to
very quickly fill out their field report
by simply taking a picture extracting
the information from the placard and
putting it into the field report then
they continue that field report when
they get out of their vehicle and they
go into the field to actually look at a
pathogen or pest problem this saves a
lot of time maybe it's just a few
minutes a day for a farmer but that
compounds for farmers around the world
every year this sort of information is
critical it has to be filed with state
regulatory and local County reports so
this information is important to get
right the Google vision API has helped
us tremendously in extracting this
information very quickly when going to
the field this is a little bit of a look
at a field report inside farm wave we
help them by recognizing the pathogens
and pests but we leverage everything in
Google cloud where farm wave lives to
get information in near real-time we
also geo tag where they are it's very
important when they go out to a field
what has happened in this field we
tagged whether what the weather was
where they are time and date the future
of farm wave next year is to launch an
app store in 2019 that allows other
machinery and data points from all
within agriculture to connect to farm
wave so we can correlate that data and
collaborate better that means if a
farmer goes back out to a field and
opens up farm wave to take a field
report it sees where they are and it
says let me pull your John Deere planter
because I know where you are and I will
tell you in a few seconds what was
planted in this field on what date what
seed what variety at what spacing at
what compaction and then let me pull
your irrigation sensor data and I will
tell you how much water this crop has
had from the day it's gone into the
ground till this very moment based off
exactly where your
it pushes those results it puts them in
the field report then you can take
pictures notes video dictation and save
it and when you save it in those
communities I mentioned earlier it gets
shared right away with your agronomists
researchers growers dealers anywhere in
the world in near real-time a few years
ago I had the pleasure of MS of visiting
with President Emmanuel macron of France
France is the capital of the world in
wine and cheese and it was fantastic to
see how they grow differently in France
than they do here in the United States
and I've been to Amman Jordan and Beirut
Lebanon and how they grow differently
there than they do in France than they
do in the United States France is one of
those countries that GMOs are prohibited
so they have different styles but data
is still is important and farmers all
around France work together through
subsidies from the government for new
technology every year we've been
visiting with France the past couple
years several times working with
different coops growers and even with
the government on how farm wave could
potentially be the single platform that
the country uses to aggregate data and
do predictive modeling in the future
because as we look at AI and as we look
at machine learning and deep learning
and what we can leverage Google cloud
platform to do
it's about those 40 chances that Howard
Buffett talked about it's about what can
we do and learn in the few for the
future based off the knowledge that we
get today I just had a conversation
recently with a lady dr. Susan
Wainwright Evans she's a world renowned
entomologist bug lady she said I'm
pretty skeptical but skeptical about
farm life Craig I come from decades of
experience and that experience in what I
do in the field we call biases in AI and
she's absolutely right there's a lot of
biases there's a lot of things that
entomologists will just see and do
just as their nature from being an
entomologist for years that are gonna be
really hard for us to train in the
system and we're working very hard on
that but the fact is dr. Susan
Wainwright Evans will not be here
forever and today it's not very popular
to be the next bug lady so we don't have
as many entomologists in 2017 alone dr.
Evans spent three weeks at home the rest
was on the road she has extremely sought
after in other countries where they see
pest infestations that they don't even
know what it is and they need her help
to save crops so working with somebody
like dr. Evans to help train our
machines to help train our AI to know
what we're looking at and pathogen or
pest infestation is critical to preserve
her knowledge of the past couple decades
for the future of Agriculture tomorrow
so we can better make decisions these
are some of the partners that we work
with obviously I talked about the
University of Georgia we did some early
work with Google X farm wave actually
began on Google glass I was an early
adopter of Google glass I went up to New
York I asked was asked to come up there
and and get a pair of Google glass and a
few months after I got it I went to a
John Deere developer conference in Des
Moines Iowa and John Deere had invited
their developers from all around the
world to come in for this conference and
it was kind of a what do you have that's
new for us and the developers were sort
of looking at John Deere saying well
what do you have that's new for us this
one gentleman came up to me he said
Craig would you get up and talk about
Google glass and and what it's doing
because a lot of people have asked us
about it and what it is said sure at
this point I'm farm wave wasn't even
born yet we had just gotten up and
talked about glass and what it was doing
out of the box and this was with the
Explorer edition and then as I learned a
little bit more about critical
problem-solving in agriculture and we
learned about the operation of a crop
scout to identify these things I knew
that we could use image recognition
technology to make these these problems
go away and make these decisions faster
so it actually began on Google glass we
did a pilot with Monsanto in 2015
on about 25 different pairs of Google
glass in Illinois where farmers were
able to go out to the field and simply
use their voice and take pictures and it
would identify or they would have the
hands-free option because of glass to
hold it up and count the kernels in a
matter of seconds and so that's some of
the work that we did early on with with
Google with Google X it still does work
today on glass and actually yesterday we
launched farm wave globally in the iOS
and Android app stores I was at an Ag
tech conference in Atlanta yesterday and
we did our global launch and we've got
80 countries and about 34,000 people in
the past 60 days who have signed up to
early adopt farm wave it's a critical
problem we are expected by 2050 for the
amount of people that will be on the
planet we have to grow more food by in
the next thirty years than we have in
the last eight thousand with less
resources less land and more mouths to
feed
technology is going to play a pivotal
role in making this happen
and we're really glad to be part of that
and we've not been able to do it without
the powerful resources of Google Cloud
within the the image recognition that
you see on this report 0 1 you'll see
that there's a map at the bottom I also
wanted to point out that the geospatial
capability when you when you take a
field report to show where you are that
populates on a map now if I'm in Iowa
and I'm growing corn and I see that I
have a problem and I'm in one of these
communities with the Iowa Corn Growers
Association and I take a picture and I
do a field report and I alert my
neighboring farmers they'll see where a
disease is actually spreading in
near-real-time
and through a dashboard view if you are
an administrator of your farm wave
community or your farm wave group you
can actually see all of the growers and
through different tags and different
tagging on the map you can actually see
it grow and spread in real time this has
an alert effect that can alert other
farmers of what's happening and what's
coming their way and it allows in that
community for those farmers to
communicate with others around the world
for advice a dairy farmer in Wisconsin
who farms about eight hundred and sixty
cows a day three times a day is pretty
advanced in in what he's doing but a
dairy farmer in India who only has eight
cows doesn't have the knowledge or the
resources or the skill set that the
gentleman in Wisconsin does through farm
wave he can send pictures and ask advice
and because those pictures are in a
field report that is location and
weather tagged the farmer in Wisconsin
can immediately advise the farmer in
India I see that you have eight cows you
live in a very humid climate here's the
conditions that you're dealing with
that's very likely mastitis and here's
what you need to do about it and that's
critical to farmers in other parts of
the world in growing countries where
those eight cows is the sustainability
of their family
[Music]